قال رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو انه لن يتنازل عن السيطره الامنيه
الاسرائيليه الكامله على جميع الاراضي
الواقعه غرب الاردن حسب قوله وكان نتنياهو
قد قال ان اسرائيل ستبقي سيطرتها الامنيه
على قطاع غزه بعد القضاء على حركه حماس
مؤكدا ان السيطرات الامنيه هي لضمان ان لا
تشكل غزه اي تهديد امني مستقبليا لاسرائيل
ونفى ديوان رئاسه الوزراء الاسرائيلي من
نقلته شبكه سي ان ان عن نتنياهو من
التزامه بخصوص الدوله الفلسطينيه خلال
اتصاله مع الرئيس بايدن مؤكدا ان نتنياهو
كرر على بايدن موقفه الثابت بخصوص الدوله
الفلسطينيه وكان الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
قد اكد ان نتنياهو لم يعارض المساله لافتا
الى ان حل الدولتين ليس مستحيلا بوجود
نتنياهو في السلطه وجاءت تصريحات الرئيس
الامريكي
بعد اتصال برئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي هو
الاول منذ نحو شهر وبحث خلاله مساله حل
الدولتين هناك عدد من الانماط لحل
الدولتين هناك عدد من الدول الاعضاء في
الامم المتحده التي ليس لديها جيوشها
الخاصه وهناك دول تخضع لقيود معينه لذا
اعتقد ان هناك طرقا يمكن لهذا الامر ان
ينجح من
خلالها